from moonshine to oatmeal to vaseline
the cast and crew of The Evil Dead had
to use some awfully strange substances
to make their movie these are some of
the wildest highlights from behind the
scenes of Sam raimi's Undead romp
clocking in with a crisp run time of 85
minutes Sam Remy's the Evil Dead wastes
no time dropping audiences straight into
the deep end not long after the spectral
title card vanishes we assume the
perspective of a lurching Steadicam a
point of view shot that doesn't so much
float as whip Karine Bob and dive
Through The Frigid Marshland of the
Tennessee Back Country after that the
first line of dialogue tells us
everything we need to know about our
protagonist situation hey Ash where are
we well we just crossed the Tennessee
Border
not after the best start as Bruce
Campbell executive producer and Ash
Williams himself describes in his
autobiography if chins could kill
Confessions of a B-movie actor the
disorientation wasn't limited to the
screen he explained right from the
get-go filming was a come of errors or
Terrors if you will within minutes of
leaving for the first location an
abandoned Bridge the production van got
lost and we'd spend a half hour trying
to locate it no sooner he'll be founded
than some drove his classic into a ditch
and we had to get a tow truck to haul it
out as if that weren't enough of a bad
Omen the crew then proceeded to hop into
a cow field occupied by an angry bovine
which chased some rainy around until the
director could scramble to safety the
dead eyes are some of the most iconic
foes in Horror history Ultra violent
wisecracking puppets for the evil that
cold Force contained in the flesh-bound
and Necronomicon ex-mortis while
deadites are distinguished by a laundry
list of unsavory descriptors from
lurching limbs to cackling laughter a
Surefire way to tell that your sister or
girlfriend has been possessed by evil is
the blank all-white eyes
see your eyes
I wish I'm scared what's wrong with her
if it was that lucky day actors simply
had their eyelids painted white as is
the case when Betsy Baker's Linda gets
decked by Ash's trusty beam of wood
while quite literally easy on the eyes
this technique did leave performers as
blind as can be ready in action
that's why more often than not the
possessed actors were outfitted with
opaque white scleral lenses these
weren't your grandma's contacts they
were enormous made of glass and covered
roughly two-thirds of the eye According
to some Remy's director's commentary the
lenses could only be worn for 15 minutes
at a time which was complicated by the
fact that it took 10 minutes to put them
on
to say that some Remy is a visually
oriented director would be an
understatement and the Evil Dead is hard
proof of this fact from its very first
moment without a doubt one of the most
mesmerizing aspects of the film that his
door-kicking approach to cinematography
cameras slam through Windows Chase
characters endlessly and protracted
tracking shots and slam repeatedly
through obstacles with ease raimi's
UniQue Ideas resulted in a number of
handmade low-tech camera rigs made out
of wooden planks these rigs allow the
low budget production to accomplish
complex expressionistic camera movements
with relative ease thanks to some
creativity and a good pile of lumber the
vasocam amounted to as Campbell puts it
a poor man's Dolly consisting of a
sawhorse a bracket and a big tub of
Vaseline the cruise no budget version of
a shaky cam rig was just a giant board
with the camera bolted onto it finally
the appropriately named ramocam allowed
the evil entity to burst through play
glass windows as Bruce Campbell
described it and if chins could kill it
was a 2x4 with a t-bar at the end which
to prevent injury by Smashing the glass
well ahead of the probing camera
Campbell hilariously added when all else
failed we just take the damn camera to
Sam raimi's hand
if you've actually seen the Evil Dead
you may be wondering why on Earth a
cabin will become the target for thieves
well once you add film gear to a remote
cabin even one is dank and dingy as the
one in the Evil Dead you invite thieves
into your life as Evil Dead crew member
Josh Becker wrote in his onset Journal
Sam raimi's solution to these worries
was to sleep in the cabin himself to
guard the equipment as Becca puts it our
director is a first-rate mess he's
sleeping at the cabin someone has to
since all our power tools were stolen
and seems to get more frazzled and less
organized by the day miraculously the
twenty thousand dollar araflex BL camera
and the five thousand dollar
reel-to-reel tape recorder was spared
from any midnight raids while the Evil
Dead producers probably didn't have room
for a security guard in their budget it
may have been smarter to have anyone
other than the director keep watch over
the valuables either way it's a
testament to the passion and dedication
Remy had for his directorial debut
well everyone's favorite final boy
didn't Chris and his boom stick formally
until Army of Darkness there's no doubt
that Ashley Williams has been making
ample use of Firepower from the get-go
as they explore the basement of the
cabin Scott and Ash come across a
sizeable shotgun lying under a beats up
poster for Wes Craven's exploitation
classic The Hills Have Eyes we're no
cold Shenanigans get out of hand and Ash
finds himself in a bleeding haunted
house the shotgun definitely comes in
handy
oh
[Music]
now if you've seen the Evil Dead you'll
know that one of the film's great charms
is its scrappiness a visceral quality
that is caused in large Parts by the
production's ragtag sensibility so when
it came to the shotgun stunts the
production team just straight up shot a
loaded shotgun live on set as Bruce
Campbell put it in an interview with DVD
talk we used real ammunition in the
shotgun and we shot it at the real cabin
in the woods with hunters and howling
dogs in the background it was an early
version of Guerrilla filmmaking nowadays
using a live weapon as a prop on a film
set is considered unacceptable both
raymie and Campbell were able to get
away with it back in the late 70s and
early 80s
during an appearance on Conan promoting
the TV show Ash vs Evil Dead Bruce
Campbell opened up about one of the more
illicit tidbits about the Evil Dead
Shoot namely that they got Stoned on set
the cast and crew were inspired by the
tale of Jack Nicholson smoking copious
amounts of marijuana before and during
the filming of Easy Rider and we thought
well if he can go on and become a very
famous notable actor we could do the
same thing
Campbell had never smoked before and the
weed that they have procured was
particularly potent needless to say not
much usable footage ended up getting
shot that night if you're wondering what
scene was specifically ruined by Mary
Jane Campbell revealed the answer
drawing his Evil Dead DVD commentary as
he tells it they were attempting to film
The Moment In which Ash and Company
gather around to listen to the recorded
reading from The Book of the Dead
lotioni was opening up the Necronomicon
a bad idea but so was toking up
beforehand
if shooting a movie in the middle of
nowhere isn't stressful enough try doing
it during the coldest winter in recent
memory that's what happened to the cast
and crew of The Evil Dead when the
film's Tennessee shoot was robbed by a
particularly brutal cold snap while the
filmmaker's home state of Michigan
enjoyed and in characteristically balmy
winter rainy and Campbell was seriously
suffering Campbell wrote in if chins
could kill the muddy driveway to the
cabin froze rendering this difficult at
Best Road impassable by car the cabin
lacking any hint of insulation
whatsoever became astoundingly cold
inside a roaring fire and two space
heaters didn't seem to help any Campbell
also recalled that the equipment
including the camera began to freeze and
needed to be regularly thought out in
front of the fire Remy's description was
a little more dramatic he said in a 1982
interview I couldn't stand the slow
torture of freezing to death so slowly
so I actually crawled outside and laid
down to die Bird's producer Rob Tapper
came outside and covered me with a
blanket and here I am today as crew
member Josh Becker wrote in his said
Journal of the production the
temperature dropped to negative 17
degrees Celsius on December 17
1979 just one degree Fahrenheit he also
roads that the crew burned some of their
Furniture to stay warm
there's a lot going on in the Evil Dead
with all the possessions ancient evils
arboreal assaults and disembodied camera
movements yet certainly be forgiven for
asking nitpicking questions like how is
a fireplace still burning through all of
this if you are paying attention to the
fire in the midst of all that chaos
would be surprised but if you've seen
the Evil Dead you'll know that the
survival of the Roaring fire is integral
to the film's Final Act in which Ash
realizes that burning the neck of
Nomicon may be the only way to end this
nightmare spoiler alerts It Isn't So
here's a director's conundrum you have a
very limited budget and your obsessed
with keeping a fire alive as an added
wrinkle it is genuinely frigid on set
meaning a roaring fire is exactly what
the doctor ordered if the director's DVD
commentary is to be believed it was
actually locally procured moonshine that
kept the fire blazing during the shoes
in January 2021 Bruce Campbell told the
Dead Eye Slayer of his time in Tennessee
we learned a lot about moonshine too
much too much
laughs
smooth
he continued the Moonshine they couldn't
drink went onto the fire just before
cameras rolled to make the Flames Roar
so simpler times but stupid at times
hell yeah
that's Ash and the Gang Drive The Long
Road up to the cabin Scott warns the
others at their destination might not
exactly be considered luxurious well the
guy that's written it says it's an old
place a little run down but it's right
up in the mountains
and the best part is we get it so cheap
Scotty's guesswork turns out to not be
that far off the cabin is absolutely
worse for wear coated in a thick layer
of cobwebs dust and pine needles thus
however rustic the cabin may appear on
the screen it's country charms pale in
comparison to what the crew had to deal
with when they first acquired the cabin
for the shoot in if chins could kill
Bruce Campbell describes the cabin's
many derelict charms in detail writing
there was no electricity no running
water and no telephone service cattle
had the run of the place and have
managed to deposit easily four inches of
manure in every room even after a home
makeover which included soaring out
windows and adding a fresh layer of
stone to the fireplace the plumbing
situation never did work out
what makes the Evil Dead cabin so Eerie
there's a dust in the air The Unfinished
walls the shed full of Bones and Rusty
tools and of course there's that dark
dung seller
Hey look
this place has a dungeon
it's in the cellar that Ash and Scotty
stumbled across the Book of the Dead and
that's where they lock up a pesky Dead
Eye that tries to tear them apart it's
also where ashtang goes with bleeding
pipes exploding light bulbs and all
manner of spine tingling third act
Shenanigans that's why fans of the Evil
Dead may find it surprising to learn
that the cabin seller didn't actually
exist at least not the way we see it as
Bruce Campbell explained on his DVD
commentary we had to dig it about four
feet down and you'd think well why
didn't they dig the rest of the cellar
because we knew there was a perfectly
good seller back up in Michigan using a
root cellar and a farmhouse outside of
Marshall Michigan is a real seller the
casting crew had to make do with a
glorified trench while filming in the
cabin keep this in mind when you see the
Shivering hacked of body parts in act
three all of which were portrayed by
actors contorted between the ground and
holes and the floorboards the reputation
of the tree Scene procedes It is
arguably one of the most infamous
sequences in Horror history and has lost
none of its skin crawling creepiness all
these decades later it's also pretty
problematic and some viewers prefer to
fast forward pasta entirely
the moment in question involves Cheryl
Williams Sister of Ash leaving the cabin
to investigate disturbing noises and
this proves to be a very bad idea as
Cheryl is attacked by gnarled creeping
vines what follows as an absurd and
deeply disturbing sexual assault scene
that aligns the Evil Dead with many of
its cohorts on the infamous video nasty
list today some Remy regrets the
sequence as he explained in a 2012
interview with the San Diego reader I
think it was a necessarily gratuitous
and a little too brutal I think my
judgment was a little wrong at that time
as with much of the Evil Dead the
visceral quality of the sequence owes a
lot to the intense way in which it was
shot particularly the latter half of the
sequence in which Cheryl runs through
the woods as Bruce Campbell pointed out
in his DVD commentary Ellen as you can
see is wearing very little these days an
actor would be padded from head to toe
that have knee pads that have elbow pads
that have butt pads that have pads for
the pads but this was 1979 with a very
rough and ready to go actress and she
was like well let's just do it gamble
described towel while filming the chase
Ellen sandwise sustained a good number
of bruises scrapes and scratches he
continued so she was a pretty good sport
it was also freezing
production of the Evil Dead was
originally scheduled for six weeks but
somewhere between the cow manure and the
Frozen cameras things were lagging
behind in fact the filmmakers were
already behind schedule before that even
called action for the first time this
caused something of an issue when the
holidays hit and the casting crew began
to dwindle leaving behind a skeleton
crew of five individuals behind to film
Ash's final descent into goopy Madness
that was where the fake Shams came in
you may have noticed a wall of names in
the end credits attributed as fake Shams
and wondered what the heck that meant
they're basically body doubles if the
actor you want isn't around for inserts
or some other shot where the face is
obscured just use whoever is on hand
speaking of hands whenever you see a
disembodied hand in the Evil Dead
there's no telling who it actually
belongs to as Bruce Campbell explains in
if chins could kill shamping takes its
name from one of the later stage three
stooges it was portrayed by a double
after the original actor suffered a
heart attack he elaborated with Evil
Dead we decided to elevate champagne to
an official on-screen credit category
Main because they soon constituted the
bulk of our cast
while it's certainly not bizarre for
films to borrow from pre-existing movies
for their sound design The Source
material for some of the noises and the
Evil Dead is definitely a little left a
field as Bruce Campbell revealed in his
DVD commentary the Ethereal atmospheric
noise you hear when the gang Ventures
down into the cellar is taken from the
renowned 1949 Orson Welles Thriller the
third man in the film's final moments as
the noises of the cabin in circle Ash we
hear the sound of footsteps on the
ceiling that's Campbell described it was
raymie walking around in a recording
studio with high heels taped to his feet
because his feet were too big to fit in
the shoes the very faint droning noise
that sometimes fills the background also
has an interesting origin while Raymond
and Campbell were missing the film back
in New York City a technical problem
caused feedback and Reverb to be
Amplified whenever the volume knob was
open Campbell wrote we could just lay
down long sections of this sound because
we thought it was a good Ambient sound
didn't cost us a nickel not long after
Ash Williams over the top yet completely
understandable meltdown another somewhat
more literal meltdown takes place after
noticing one of the deadite smoking when
the Necronomicon Falls precariously
close to the Roaring fire Ashley
heroically chunks a nefarious book
deeper into the Flames sure enough the
formerly Lively Dead Eye begins
decomposing before our very eyes rotting
in hyperspeed as their skin peels back
to reveal bone gross and identifiable
goop and flailing tongues then if all
that weren't dramatic enough Claude
hands burst through the necrotic flesh
sending what's left of the corpses
hurtling to the floor will they explode
like pinatas if pinatas were full of
jawbones slime mold and creepy crawlies
as Bruce Campbell relayed in if chins
could kill the sequence required three
months of Animation work courtesy of
Bart Pierce they've been tasked with
making sure the film ended on a bang the
melting scene included everything from
oatmeal to cockroaches but Campbell
really sold the ick Factor when he
revealed that the monster gut substance
that was hooked at his face was made of
elbow dog food it was the last scene in
the film that Campbell shot and having a
kind of processed animal food sprayed on
his face by its old Pals some Remy
seemed like a good enough way as Annie
to finish off the wild experience
foreign